hey chef hey New Kids on the Block here
is from Iowa really ask you this a lot
of oceans in Iowa
no just ponds and lakes and cocky pretty
boys in much what happened to that last
freeware recruit we have you guys what
is this lifeguard hazing I met Brody
told the world record the 200-meter hey
Brody
that Brody yes absolutely we still never
really heard a guy sing that song but it
was really good thank you
by the way when we shower in here we
come huh
you just a stick at my booth I was not
my intention I didn't you like him right
now now I did because we were talking
about testing out failed oh my god okay
you just like this one again
[Music]
[Music]
you never forget the one who steals your
heart or the one Oh
who kicks your ass some base you [ __ ] is
happening in our Beach and my balls say
we need to go over there and check it
out good Valley damage
we're lifeguards my balls day just
thinking he's ready for my balls are
saying [ __ ] that noise let's go handle
business your balls are bullies they
watch work because we follow rules
this time train wreck I'm never OD and
not a single [ __ ] was given what a bet
for is in the whole world would like if
a human [ __ ] again T which is
impossible to be so cool like me there's
a cop don't jack off on my sheep
remember I'm always watching I know how
to do that Leon patience matters
[Music]
Oh
Oh
All Things Considered being out of work
what that's good luck pick it up my dog
we need to search for more evidence
check his paint for needle marks you
want me to check his taint lift his
[ __ ] scrotum can check his taint there
is a taint man it's--it ain't even look
get closer
oh holy yogurt oh there is a hole that's
just his butthole smile most of that do
not post at just a head full of ball set
[Music]
he turns canals into the goddamn X Games
it's because we were in lifeguard
pursuit oh okay
love it except for there's no [ __ ]
such thing as lifeguard pursuit
[Music]
you